revealing your gender identity is tough
really for any adult but in the Asian
Community it can present some unique
hurdles May is Asian American and
Pacific Islander month and eight news
now reporter Mary Jane beliesa shares
how one local non-profit is working to
break down that stigma
coming out of the closet is a personal
choice and for the Asian and Pacific
Islander Community coming out to family
and friends can be challenging due to
cultural expectations and traditions
Preston tanks has he felt those societal
pressures as a Vietnamese American
growing up in a religious household so a
struggle growing up and I didn't know
resources because my parents were first
generation so the fact this this seek
mental health counseling to seek
resources out can be seen such as a
stigma as a shame to the family and it
shouldn't be that way through that need
Tang also works with young adults on sex
education and HIV prevention why is
there no no youth Advocate or no
organization that caters to the API
community and we're like you know what
let's let's create an organization out
of our passion that's when the Southern
Nevada Asian and Pacific Islander queer
Society also known as snap Hicks was
created in 2019 as the public relations
chairperson Tang helps organize monthly
events through the center Asian American
Development Council and works with Asian
businesses to create safe places so
we're gonna have open and print
conversation about our API Journey being
Queer as well as uh touching very touchy
topics such as sexuality sex and prevent
education and resources and if not if
they need access to counseling Tang says
the biggest need that they see from
people they help are Mental Health
Services according to Tang snap picks
has helped prevent tense suicides so far
we want to make sure that we create
sustainable change in the future so that
teacher generation do not have to steal
the same impact that we did growing up
as queer API folks
now the organization already has around
300 members in Las Vegas and all of
their resources are free